before applying to law school in the US
students need to take an exam called the
LSAT before applying to medical school
students need to take an exam called the
MCAT
here are some summary statistics for
each exam so the LSAT the mean score is
151 with a standard deviation of 10 and
the MCAT the mean score is 25 point one
with a standard deviation of 6.4 Juwan
took both exams
he scored 172 on the LSAT and 37 on the
MCAT which exam did he do relatively
better on so pause this video and see if
you can figure it out so the way I would
think about it is you can't just look at
the absolute score because they are on
different scales and they have different
distributions but we can use this
information if we assume it's the normal
distribution or relatively close to a
normal distribution with a meat centered
at this mean we can think about well how
many standard deviations from the mean
did he score in each of these situations
in both cases he scored above the mean
but how many standard deviations above
the mean so let's see if we can figure
that out so in the LSAT let's see let me
write this down on the LSAT he scored
172 so how many standard deviations is
that going to be let's take 172 his
score minus the mean so this is the
absolute number that he scored above the
mean and now let's divide that by the
standard deviation so on the LSAT this
is what this is going to be 21 divided
by 10 so this is 2.1 standard deviations
deviations above the mean above the mean
you could view this as a z-score it's a
z-score of 2.1
we are two point one above the mean in
this situation now let's think about how
he did on the MCAT on the MCAT he scored
a 37 the mean is a 25 point one and
there is a standard deviation of six
point four so let's see 37 point one
minus 25 would be 12 but now it's going
to be eleven point nine 11
point nine divided by six point four so
without even looking at this so this is
this is going to be approximately well
this is going to be a little bit less
than two this is going to be less than
two so based on this information and we
could figure out the exact number here
in fact let me get my calculator out so
you get the calculator so if we do
eleven point nine divided by six point
four that's going to get us to one point
I'll just say one point I would say
approximately one point eight six so
approximately one point eight six so
relatively speaking he did slightly
better on the LSAT there's more he did
more standard deviations although this
is close I would say they're comparable
he did roughly two standard deviations
if we were round to the nearest standard
deviation but if you wanted to get
precise he did a little bit better
relatively speaking on the LSAT he did
two point one standard deviations here
while over here he did one point eight
six or one point nine standard
deviations but in everyday language you
would probably say well this is this is
comparable if this was three standard
deviations and this is one standard
deviation then you'd be like oh he
definitely did better on the LSAT